obrigado gente o projeto aqui com vocês
momento eu tenho um pouquinho de
ansiedade é natural esperado
a grande pergunta o que vai acontecer
vou falar sobre o que a gente acha que
deveria acontecer às pessoas mas as
dificuldades que o país tem é quem
enfrentar a gente quiser voltar a
crescer e tem uma voltagem um cenário de
normalidade chrome geral é portador de
más notícias não só ter um pouco de
paciência né
o primeiro país da crise fiscal ele sabe
disso que escoltam maneira simples
traduzir como o dinheiro é meu dinheiro
quero fazer não tem dinheiro
hoje se pode botar uma platéia não tem
gelo como acabou o dia todinho dia acaba
em números de hoje cento e um por cento
da receita mágica receita está
comprometido com gastos fixados em lei
várias emendas constitucionais outros o
resto diferença 60% e previdência
assistência um pedaço transferências a
estados e municípios têm gastos
obrigatórios constitucionais com saúde
educação por aí vai
o governo federal dos engenheiros do
estado também tem vários estados em que
a folha de pagamentos ativos e inativos
é maior do que a arrecadação
esse é um problema imediato porque se
não tem dinheiro
uma de três coisas vão acontecer vai
parar de pagar a conta e tem status
parcela do salário atrasado fornecedores
da calote como a inflação em relação à
maneira saborosa do estado se financiar
uma maneira o estado tem que arrecadar
recursos mas que é totalmente
disfuncional para a economia os mais
jovens aí não passaram por isso a minha
geração de alguns que estão aqui
passaram ea gente está vendo aqui no
vizinho nós aqui do lado da argentina o
que
acontece se você vai tentar resolver é
esse problema devagarzinho a economia
fica frágil vem uma ventania de fora
lá vem a crise não é isso que a gente
quer
o problema imediato resolveu fiscal e
não tem jeito
o fiscal resultado das nossas escolhas o
fiscal resultado nas contas públicas os
gastos obrigatórios
é o resultado das escolhas que a
sociedade fez ao longo das últimas três
décadas onde gastar o dinheiro
só que é importante reservar o dinheiro
faz uma lei só que é importante reservar
o dinheiro na constituição aquilo ali
também é importante reservar uma lei e
esse somatório de decisões foram tomadas
por nós os nossos representantes que
levaram a essa crise o que quer dizer
que sair desse problema passa pela
política possa ter a negociação passa
por acordos passa por negociar encontrar
soluções
olha hoje nós vamos cortar onde vai
crescer menos um candidato natural e
previdência onde o brasil é um país
muito diferente do resto do mundo
não tem país reconheça que se aposenta
em média um homem um homem mercado
formal da renda mais alta sociedade
aí os 5% mais ricos de seu conjunto
representa em média aos 55 anos em média
como médio na lista completa com menos
tem remédio
nesta gente abaixo assim as mulheres 53
no resto do mundo como é que num ritmo
diferente
o resto não tem idade mínima mínima
feminio a média acima mínima 62 65 67
alguns anos 70 anos
esse é um exemplo onde o brasil
diferente as regras servidor público
também são diferentes daquilo que estava
fora acúmulo de benefícios também aqui a
diferença mas fora pensão por morte
também aqui é diferente da de fora a
gente faz tudo diferente e acho que vai
dar certo pois é não deu
eles querem da argentina do chile do
méxico e dos estados unidos da
inglaterra da suécia
esse é o primeiro candidato tem um
sistema de contenção enfrentados porque
a previdência é fala é fazer com que os
gastos parem de crescer tão rapidamente
os gaúchos presentes em crescendo ea
razão é boa gente razão que boa parte é
preocupante
a parte boa estamos vivendo mais
a geração dos meus pais acreditem ou não
os jovens tinha mais de seus filhos por
casal
mas seus filhos efe seis filhos
cresci amigos com oito irmãos nove
irmãos normal
acesse muito mais ainda a minha geração
foi beneficiada com a melhora da
qualidade de vida melhorou saneamento
melhorou vacinação atenção cuidado
resultado a mortalidade infantil
diminuiu então nasce é muita gente e
pouco peru que boa notícia
essa geração chegou no mercado trabalho
70 80
muita gente ao mesmo tempo trabalhando
mais gente trabalhando mais gente
trabalhando mais crescimento
não porque cada um está ganhando muito
mais mas que tem mais gente trabalhando
a nova geração a geração jovem menos de
dois filhos por casal
1.7 1.8 então quando eu era jovem nos
anos 80
já fui jovem anos 80 é chamado pirâmide
demográfica tinha muita gente
recém nascida algumas como um número
grande de pessoas com 20 anos pouco
menor com 30 40 e poucos idosos é uma
pirâmide hoje vai a nossa pirâmide
demográfica ter um senhor barbudo tem
pouca gente está sendo menos já está
sendo
tem muita gente no mercado trabalho
entre 20 e 60 anos e tem um número maior
de idosos o que tinha no passado
já já vai vai piorar o quadro o número
de idosos vai crescer mais de duas vezes
nas próximas décadas eo número de
pessoas que trabalha vai cair os 6 7%
nas próximas décadas tem menos gente
trabalhando muito mais
sentados com detalhes de quem paga a
aposentadoria aqui trabalhando agora eu
que trabalho contribui com a previdência
para aposentadoria de quem está
aposentado
ou a gente faz uma reforma da
previdência de verdade séria profunda ou
a nova geração podem trabalhar muito
mais para sustentar os aposentados ou
não vai pagar com sabedoria e civil em
vários estados mas de novo essa
discussão uma questão da política
sociedade negociar como ex da reforma o
tempo de transição vão dar um tratamento
privilegiado setor público ou não
como é que cuida dos grupos mais
vulneráveis e não para aí e os subsídios
e incentivos fiscais
essa agenda não se esgota em uma duas
três cinco medidas é preciso muito mais
do que isso para enfrentar o problema
fiscal
ele sempre passa pela política
a boa notícia é que a gente conseguiu
enfrentar esse problema ao longo dos
próximos dois três anos
os treinos soluções reduzir o
crescimento dos gastos cortando alguns
gastos reduzindo alguns benefícios
o brasil tem uma oportunidade imensa de
crescimento à frente
nós temos tantas distorções da economia
o sistema de tributário complicado se
tornou disfuncional quem está no mundo
real conhece isso temos um posto
solucionado por estado que é um outro
publicitário é uma confusão regras
tributárias complexas a barra será o
chocolate é será o chocolate não sei
depende da tributação não sei
chocolate amargo tributária será outro
os diversos produtos em área diferente
água de cheiro na colônia que é perfume
da creche tributária não dá não sei
depende nem sentar sair
o lanche que você paga no avião
o imposto é cobrado onde na partida na
chegada
sou exemplo os pitorescos a complexidade
do tema tributário resulta nesse
contencioso e menos que o país vive essa
má notícia é boa a gente comece a
enfrentar os problemas
o país cresce mais isso reduz custos
necessário isso melhora a produtividade
ea gente acerto fiscal se as contas
públicas cariocas
a insegurança sobre o futuro seja duas
semanas eu tenho um problema fiscal mais
uma investida
eu sei o quanto é impossível pagar o que
vem daqui a dois anos três anos por meio
do cálculo no plano de negócio não sei
não sei mas eu não posso ter mais esse
semestre a ter mais semelhanças vai ter
mais imposto de renda mas dividendo a
pagar imposto a pagar imposto a investir
que está no mundo real e vencia isso o
tempo todo porque as regras tributárias
as dobras e interpretações mudam e
comércio exterior também cheio de regra
específica caso particular e portais
difícil complicado caro custoso ea
tecnologia que eu descobri lá fora pois
é a demora para chegar aqui chega mais
caro mais difícil mais chuvosa não tem
máquina boa lá fora que não consigo
fazer o brasil tem regras de conteúdo
nacional na hora de comprar do
brasileiro
vamos gerar emprego no brasil mas isso
lá de fora é melhor é sinto muito mas e
aí ficaremos produtivo eu vou gerar
menos emprego é verdade
nós entramos na última década esse
retrocesso dessa agenda protecionista de
incentivos de benefícios tributários
para antónio mas não para joão de
proteger o setor ar o produto b e isso
gerou essa complexidade adicional
investir no brasil foi mais difícil
ficou difícil produzir energia ficou
difícil iniciar uma fábrica
os conflitos se somam não temos bons
mecanismos para mediar conflitos
eu quero que os fabrica mas isso é
complicado derrubar algo mais
árvores que eu posso plantar em outro
lugar deveria ser o o o processo simples
negociação de conflitos não é esse
processo vai demorar anos
licenciamento porque tão complicado
neste encontro a favor não é isso
é o conflito sem disfuncional ver
necessariamente logo demasiado incerto
história país mais pobre
essa é uma agenda boa ser enfrentado
se nós conseguirmos com o país negociais
conflitos melhor forma enfrentar os
problemas começara paulatinamente
imagina de reforma tributária uma
abertura organizada uma agenda de
mediação de conflitos mais eficaz a
produtividade aumenta o investimento
aumenta o emprego renda e o país pode
voltar a uma normalidade de crescimento
essa é a oportunidade que nós temos mais
novo pai e isso passa por manutenção
passa por encontrar soluções e as
soluções passam pelo legislativo várias
passam também pelo judiciário
a situação de confronto de conflito que
o país atravessa
fica difícil construir soluções cada
grupo defende o seu interesse nessa
guerra de guerrilha de cada um cada um
desses protegendo ficamos mais fotos
estabelecer o diálogo a capacidade de
conversa e negociação é fundamental
nesse processo
e esse não é um trabalho da economia do
trabalho da política
o economista serve a política
nosso papel é servir encontra um sonho é
das restrições o melhor possível a ser
construído é coisa da sociedade
mediada pela política
a técnica tem que ser respeitada porque
se diz respeito à técnica vira tiro no
pé
essas distorções na economia surgiram
pessoas muito bem intencionados
elas achavam que ser o caminho do
desenvolvimento
vamos fortalecer a petrobras vamos dar
crédito subsidiado
vamos estimular o investimento privado
ou proteger e proteção da produção local
e com isso aumentar o investimento
aumentar o emprego e poder mágico pois é
errado
os negócios ficaram de pé as placas e
eficiente a produtividade da economia
caiu a petrobras quase foi para o saco
a falta de técnica leva a decisões
equivocadas mas o norte rumo destino ea
negociação para chegar lá nunca técnica
mas sim a política mas ainda a gestão da
política econômica
não sou não se resume a três quatro
ideias que uma vez aprovados o mundo se
reorganiza e vamos embora essas
negociações necessárias são resultado de
anos e anos de falta de atenção com a
política econômica do descuido com a
negociação
todo dia tem 34 57 medidas no congresso
são liberadas decisões do judiciário
se a técnica não está ao lado informando
as consequências
eles vão ocorrendo nos últimos meses o
que foi aprovado de medidas que vão dar
uma imensa dor de cabeça no país nos
próximos anos é impressionante
cada medida entra não vão adicionar a
quina vão proteger a cidade está o
estado tal o setor tal e essa conta está
aumentando
agora sem o diálogo da técnica apoiando
a política explicando ea sociedade ea
política negociando de forma organizada
esses conflitos o resultado dessa
organização que nós estamos vivendo um
momento natural de ansiedade
todos nós estamos passando mas é melhor
forma a restabelecer o diálogo e o
diálogo não é com o que concorda com a
gente concordar conversar com quem
concorda com a gente é fácil concordar
com quem pensa igual é fácil
bom mesmo é conversar com quem pensa
diferente
construir solução quem discorda
o nosso caminho as saídas dos problemas
não passa pelo confronto violento não
passa pela reorganização das
divergências o caminho para enfrentar os
problemas passa pelo diálogo pela boa fé
pelo convite
a conversa mesmo sabendo que ela vai ser
difícil mas nós conversarmos
não vamos reclamar daqui a dois anos
daqui a três anos que não deu certo a
culpa vai ter o nosso obrigado